and finally new rule the people of
planet Earth's have to ask have to ask
themselves one question why did we put
this guy in charge is he even one of us
a human he he looks like a first attempt
at whittling a puppet
[Laughter]
and why is the world's most socially
awkward person in charge of social media
you can't watch the news these days
without seeing some story about Facebook
hosting Russian BOTS cellaring user data
and getting into cryptocurrency refusing
to fact-check political ads and it keeps
growing you know after we found out last
year that Facebook had wrongly given out
the personal information of 50 million
people there was a big backlash in a
movement called hashtag delete Facebook
well at hashtag didn't [ __ ] work
Facebook has only gotten bigger and
let's face it social media is where the
world increasingly gets its news so
maybe now would be a good time to
remember how the whole thing got started
and it wasn't because Mark Zuckerberg
had a calling to birth the world with a
more informed populace is because he
started a website that gave college
dudes the chance to rape women whose
pictures he hacked from Harvard's Data
Bank yes the most powerful man in the
news business got there by inventing a
hot-or-not site and when you look at the
world of likes that Facebook has spawned
look at this post from Chora my facebook
photos don't get as many likes as other
peoples does that mean I'm ugly you have
to ask has it changed that much
courts on the bright side Facebook has
solved many crimes like the ones where
the genius thieves post pictures of the
heist because that's what Facebook does
- it makes you stupider because there
are only so many hours in a day and you
can get only so much accomplished if you
are constantly checking to see what
everybody you ever met
had for lunch people are dumber because
they read less Facebook should be called
time suck
and now Zuckerberg has decided Facebook
will not be policing political speech on
their site or fact-checking any
political ads and this only applies to
politics other stuff still has rules on
Facebook you cannot say Pizza Hut
murders puppies and puts it in the sauce
but you can say Pizza Hut murders
puppies and puts it in the sauce on
orders from Bernie Sanders and I hate to
tell you but that's the way it should be
do you want political speech policed by
the accuracy regulation departments at
Facebook and Twitter not me I'm always
going to come down on the side of free
speech the parameters of which have been
debated for centuries by our finest
legal minds and also Clarence Thomas
and figuring out when politicians are
full of [ __ ] is the responsibility of
the voters and no one else
people have to build up an immunity to
falsehoods we can't pass the buck to a
referee because a referee is still human
and even if we used a computer to do it
Trump would say the computer was an
angry Democrat there is another solution
don't use Facebook at all I never got
them I never got the whole point of
staying in touch with so many people I
don't really care about maybe because I
grew up on classic rock where the songs
were always about moving on papa was a
rolling stone Freebird ramblin man go
your own way now no one moves on y-you
don't need to follow Gary from high
school who was your lab partner in chem
class
you forgot chem you can forget him
you don't need his status update his
status as he never left town and guess
what because of Facebook you haven't
either just remember not everyone you've
ever crossed paths with is meant to be
in your consciousness forever
some people come into your life touch
you and then leave
they're called Scout masters all right
you